لكن مشاهدينا لماذا تصاعد ذات حده
التوترات بين واشنطن وبيكين خلال الفتره
الاخيره السبب يعودوا الى تراكم الخلافات
من ابرزها وطبعا وفق خبراء تايوان وبحر
الصين الجنوبي والقيود التي فرضها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن على صادرات رقائق اشباه
الموصلات الى الصين ففي الوقت الذي تكثف
فيه الصين من ضغوطها العسكريه والسياسيه
لاجبار الجزيره على قبول متطلبات بكين
بالسياده والتي ترفضها طبعا حكومه بشده
توسع الولايات المتحده من انشطتها حول
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ لمواجهه مطالبات
الصين وزير الدفاع الامريكي اوستن تعهد
بان واشنطن لن تؤيد ما وصفه بالترهيب
الصيني لحلفائها بل تفضل الحوار على
الصراع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات